im studio begrüße ich professor frank
decker von der universität bonn guten
abend gute nacht bei aller
ernsthaftigkeit dieser debatte
vielleicht auch bei aller staatsraison
die bei diesen themen ja auch eine rolle
spielt wie intensiv ist denn dieses
kräftemessen jetzt zwischen regierung
und opposition vielleicht auch zwischen
stolz und märz also es ist natürlich
viel intensiver als das was wir in zwölf
der letzten 16 jahre hatten nämlich eine
konstellation mit einer großen koalition
die beiden größten parteien bilden die
regierung die im grunde nicht gut ist
für den parlamentarismus und man kann
jetzt in den 100 tagen schon sehen die
debatten werden interessanter es gibt
tatsächlich einen schlagabtausch
zwischen regierung und opposition und es
tut der parlamentarischen demokratie gut
wenn die opposition von einer der beiden
volksparteien oder noch volksparteien
angeführt wird und der neue
oppositionsführer ist ein guter
rhetoriker ist angriffslustig und
insoweit rückt der bundestag jetzt auch
wieder etwas mehr in den blickpunkt des
öffentlichen interesses
aber der begriff rhetoriker bringt einen
natürlich schon auf eine spur also ich
meine bei den themen ukraine bei den
themen corona wieviel unterschiede gibt
es denn wirklich und wie viel ist
gespielte polit streit ja das ist
natürlich ein ganz interessanter punkt
schon beinahe war es eigentlich so dass
das kein parteipolitisches thema ist die
afg hat dort natürlich eine andere
position vertreten ein stück weit auch
die fdp aber ansonsten gab es unter den
anderen parteien und das trägt ja bis
heute durch einen weitgehenden
konsens wir hatten eher
auseinandersetzung zwischen bund und
ländern als
zwischen den parteien und in der
außenpolitik ist es natürlich jetzt auch
für die opposition eine schwierige
situation weil sie sich grundsätzlich
natürlich auch hinter die regierung und
den kurs der regierung stellen muss
erkennen sie möglicherweise auch eine
taktik der opposition eine taktik der
union jetzt bei einigen punkten so zu
sagen vielleicht deals auszuhandeln um
auf anderen gebieten dann automatisch
mehr einfluss zu haben das ist natürlich
immer auch ein dilemma für die
opposition die union kontrolliert ja
auch die mehrheit der länder im
bundesrat deren stimmen sie dann
zumindest theoretisch neutralisieren
könnte aber wir haben es ja schon beim
infektionsschutzgesetz gesehen am ende
ist ja dann doch nichts anderes übrig
geblieben als zuzustimmen was aber
sicherlich die taktik das haben wir
heute gesehen sein wird der opposition
ist natürlich die ampel parteien
gegeneinander auszuspielen denn die fdp
war ja immer der wunsch
koalitionspartner
und wenn man es jetzt sich das heute
angeschaut hat die haben sich auch am
stärksten gegenseitig
behagt nur und natürlich gibt es dort in
der ampelkoalition auch große
meinungsunterschiede
ich denke märz ist vielleicht ein stück
zu weit gegangen heute in dem er gesagt
hat es muss im grunde immer sicher sein
dass die ampel eine eigene mehrheit hat
also das funktioniert ja schon von der
technik der abstimmungen nicht aber ich
denke das ist sicherlich die die
strategie sozusagen die ampel soll in
der internen uneinigkeit zu kritisieren
und sehen sie die gefahr dass manche
entscheidung durch diese streitereien
dann unglaublich verzögert wird also
beispiel impfpflicht kommt jetzt dann
erst zu weihnachten
wenn sie überhaupt kommt bei corona
haben wir natürlich jetzt die situation
dass die außenpolitik der der krieg in
der ukraine alles andere überlagert also
es gibt im grunde gar keine möglichkeit
mehr auch für das thema aufmerksamkeit
zu gewinnen
aber ich glaube es wäre ohnehin
schwierig geworden in der unter den
jetzigen bedingungen das sehen wir auch
in anderen ländern österreich musste die
impfpflicht wieder zurücknehmen eine
weitergehende impfpflicht also etwa der
weitestgehende entwurf ist ja ab 18
jahren durchzusetzen ich glaube dazu
wird es nicht kommen wir noch mal kurz
auf die ukraine zu sprechen kommen ist
gab er vergangene woche schon einen sehr
spannenden augenblick als selensky im
bundestag gesprochen hat per
videoschalte und anschließend war nix
und alle haben das als peinlichen moment
gewertet manche haben sogar von schande
gesprochen und da hat zum beispiel der
oppositionsführer da hat unions und
fraktionschef märz dann blitzschnell
angegriffen und gesagt ja also wir
würden wann wenn nicht jetzt auch eine
debatte führen wollen
hätte man das tun müssen absolut also da
hatte er in der sache wirklich recht
olaf scholz hat es ja heute versucht
auch bisschen wieder gut zu machen aber
die rede die er heute gehalten hat er
hat der see lenzing auch direkt
adressiert die hätte er in der letzten
woche hat überall ganz kurz nur heute
oder sogar gesagt wir schaffen das hat
er auch noch frau merkel zitiert ja das
zeigt sich jetzt in solchen situationen
versammeln sich die die wähler auch dann
hinter der regierung er muss genau auf
diese führungsstärke jetzt ausstrahlt
und zumindestens für die ampelkoalition
wir haben ja am sonntag auch wahlen im
saarland zahlt sich das jetzt
demoskopisch aus denn die regierung
hatte ja keinen guten start das corona
management war nicht gut eigentlich
einen fehlstart aber jetzt sind die
politischen vorzeichen natürlich ganz
andere professor frank decker vielen
dank für diese anordnungen schön dass du
da aber gerne